[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir le retour de blaise compaoré
au burkina faso information confirmée
par le gouvernement burkinabè il est
attendu avant la fin de la semaine les
détails avec notre correspondant à
ouagadougou abdoulaye barry la première
rencontre entre paul kagame et félix
tshisekedi depuis l' escalade de
tensions entre la république
démocratique du congo et le rwanda des
tensions liées à la recrudescence de
violence entre eux dans l'est de la rdc
les deux présidents se sont accordés sur
une feuille de route pour imposer leurs
relations les détails dans ce journal
ces arrestations guinée plusieurs
membres du front national pour la
défense de la constitution ont été
violemment interpellé mardi par la
police une arrestation suite à des
déclarations visant le parlement de
transition et la justice on sera à
conakry dans ce journal
après huit ans d'exil forcé en côte
d'ivoire l'ancien président burkinabè
blaise compaoré renversé en 2014 par une
insurrection populaire va rentrer dans
son pays il est attendu à ouagadougou
avant la fin de la semaine il doit
rencontrer le nouvel homme fort du pays
le lieutenant-colonel damiba écouter
d'ici la fin de la semaine une rencontre
importante entre les différents chefs
d'état les anciens chefs d'état du
burkina faso sera organisée dans le but
justement
d'accélérer la question de la
réconciliation mais aussi de mutualiser
les énergies
énergie pour sauvegarder ce qu'il ya de
plus précieux à nos yeux c'est à dire
l'existence du jour de notre terre le
burkina faso et la solidarité pour
lutter donc efficacement contre la
tragédie qui nous fera part mais aussi
réduire les factures internet
un retour très scrutées par la
population pour rappel blaise compaore
avait été jugé par contumace et condamné
à la prison à vie si dans le procès des
assassins de thomas sankara la
correspondance à ouagadougou abdoulaye
barry
selon plusieurs sources proches de la
présidence le lieutenant-colonel damiba
rencontrera dès ce vendredi les anciens
chefs d'état burkinabè blaise compaore
roch marc christian kaboré jean baptiste
ouédraogo
cependant des doutes planant sur la
participation de deux anciens chefs
d'état à cette rencontre dite de haut
niveau sur les questions liées à
l'intérêt supérieur de la nation il
s'agit notamment des yacouba isaac sida
en exil au canada et de l'ancien
président de la transition michel
kafando dont la santé serait fragile
blaise compaoré à ouagadougou quelques
mois seulement après avoir été condamné
par contumace à la perpétuité dans le
dossier sankara c'est une véritable
douche froide pour la famille et les
partisans de thomas sankara cependant
une note de la direction de la
communication de la présidence indique
que cette rencontre ne devrait pas
entraver les poursuites judiciaires
engagées contre certaines personnalités
notamment blaise compaore
va-t-on vers une désescalade entre le
rwanda et la république démocratique du
congo c'est en tout cas la volonté des
deux présidents qui se sont rencontrés
aujourd'hui à luanda ce mercredi paul
kagame et félix tshisekedi ont entamé
des entretiens dans le cadre d'une
médiation conduite par l'angola il
s'agit de la première rencontre entre
les deux présidents depuis la
recrudescence de violences dans l'est de
la rdc la correspondance à kinshasa de
clément bongo
selon un communiqué de la présidence
congolaise félix tshisekedi et paul
kagame se sont mis d'accord ce mercredi
pour engager un processus de désescalade
entre leurs deux pays les relations
entre kinshasa et kigali se sont
considérablement dégradées ces dernières
semaines depuis la reprise des
affrontements entre l'armée congolaise
et le m23 la rdc accuse le rwanda de
soutenir cette milice une rébellion à
dominante tutsie défaite en 2013 mais
qui a fait son retour en novembre
dernier de son côté le rwanda nie toute
implication et accusent l'armée
congolaise de coopérer avec les fdlr un
groupe armé rwandais dont certains
membres ont perpétré le génocide de 1994
contre les tutsis ce mercredi sous la
médiation du président angolais joão
lourenço félix tshisekedi et paul kagame
se sont finalement entendus sur une
feuille de route pour apaiser ces
tensions et ont affirmé leur volonté
d'une normalisation des relations
diplomatiques
cette feuille de route prévoit la
cessation immédiate des hostilités
ainsi que le retrait immédiat et sans
concession du m23 à de ses positions en
rdc les deux pays ont par ailleurs
accepté de relancer leur commission
mixte bilatérale
il s'agit d'un cadre de dialogue
permanent entre les deux pays qui ne
s'était pas réunie depuis plusieurs
années une première réunion est prévue
le 12 juillet prochain à luanda
cette arrestation musclée andine et
plusieurs membres du front national pour
la défense de la constitution était
violemment interpellé mardi par la
police à à conakry une arrestation suite
à des déclarations visant le parlement
de transition et la justice les détails
avec notre correspondant m'anime
d'équité
dans cette vidéo d'une extrême brutalité
qui fait le tour des réseaux sociaux on
voit le coordinateur général du fdc
phonique et mangue est en train d'être
traînés au sol la parade des policiers
puis j'étais dans un pick up à ses côtés
le rappeur jenny alpha et même en 2000
obara responsable de la mobilisation du
fdc cinq militants faisaient face à la
presse pour dénoncer les poursuites du
procureur général de conakry pour des
faits présumés de désagréments de la
justice guinéenne mais aussi pour des
enjeux publics sur les réseaux sociaux
pour loger des assure l'organisation
guinéenne de défense des droits de
l'homme cette interpellation est une
violation des principes démocratiques
on a l'impression que le système que
nous avons combattu pendant des années
est toujours en place et ça c'est un
vrai regret pour tous les défenseurs des
droits de l'homme parce qu'aujourd'hui
les acquis que nous avons à obtenir dans
le sens dans la douleur et parfois au
prix d'innombrables vies est en train
d'être remis en cause et nous enfonçons
inéluctablement vers la bible qui n'est
pas possible car après ce tendre lutte
que la liberté d'expression soit
confisquée par le cnds un gouvernement
très tôt ce mercredi matin sur l'axé
hamdallaye bambeto cosa en banlieue de
conakry des affrontements ont éclaté
entre les forces de l'ordre et des
jeunes manifestants qui réclament la
libération des détenus le fdc compte
organiser une manifestation de rue pour
réclamer je cite la libération des
détenus politiques
ces attaques au niger à peine un peu
plus d'une semaine après le passage du
président mohamed bazoum la région de
diffa et de nouveau cible et dimanche
puis lundi plusieurs dizaines de membres
de boko haram ont attaqué des groupes de
soldats nigériens ont fait le point avec
notre correspondant à niamey harold
girard
dimanche un militaire a perdu la vie
dans la nuit de lundi à mardi ses six
autres soldats qui ont été tués boko
haram veut réaffirmer sa présence dans
la région de diffa depuis plusieurs
semaines après quelques mois d'accalmie
ces attaques en ce début juillet elles
sont attendues par les autorités elles
interviennent juste avant les plus
fortes pluies de l'année dans la région
c'est à ce moment là que les cours d'eau
remontent et que la tâche devient de
plus en plus compliqué pour les
assaillants terroristes selon plusieurs
sources sécuritaires le groupe
terroriste boko haram n'a plus les
moyens de mener des attaques d'ampleur
le résultat du renforcement de la
capacité mais aussi de la cohésion des
armes et des différents pays qui
composent la région du lac tchad et qui
agissent ensemble de plus en plus
efficacement depuis quelques mois
maintenant ouais
pourquoi les pays de la région du lac
tchad ont-ils eu de mauvais résultats au
début parce qu'il manquait de main
d'oeuvre et de logistique élaboré mais
de nombreux pays ont investi surtout le
nigeria et le niger
ils ont utilisé des drones et ont
amélioré leurs opérations sur le terrain
c'est pour cela qu'on observe désormais
de bons résultats
les autres le président nigérien mohamed
bazoum lui était à diffa le 26 juin
dernier pour inciter les déplacés
internes nigérien à retourner chez eux
dans leur village qu'ils ont laissées
sous les coups de la violence c'est un
marathon qu'il a commencé il ya
maintenant plus d'un mois à travers le
niger mais du côté des humanitaires on
alerte face au projet du gouvernement de
ramener près de quarante mille personnes
dans plusieurs dizaines de villages de
la région de diffa plusieurs projets
similaires ont déjà échoué ces dernières
années à cause d'une situation restait
instable
au soudan le général putschiste
abdelfettah el bola n'a commencé à
mettre en place son plan pour former un
gouvernement civil mais les manifestants
mobilisés contre le pouvoir militaire
reste méfiant il appelle à maintenir la
pression sur nbc
soudanaises ont investi les rues de
khartoum par centaines comme des
milliers d'autres habitants elle réclame
le départ du général putschiste
abdelfattah al burhan au pouvoir depuis
2000 19 le but est de montrer que nous
sommes positionnés au sein de la
révolution quelles que soient nos
différences les filles et les garçons
travaillent main dans la main ce sont
les jeunes qui sacrifient leur vie et
font vivre la lutte depuis maintenant
une semaine le mouvement de contestation
ne faiblit pas et ce malgré la promesse
du chef militaire de mai 30 place un
gouvernement civil un gouvernement qui
l'avait pourtant limogé en octobre
dernier depuis ce sont les militaires
qui ont les pleins pouvoirs au soudan
pourtant en avril 2019 après huit mois
de sit in qui ont provoqué le départ
d'omar el béchir les manifestants
avaient obtenu un partage du pouvoir
entre civils et militaires
un conseil souverain de transition avait
été formé la plus haute autorité du pays
est aujourd'hui amenés à être remplacés
d'après le général al bourhane il
affirme qu'il souhaite à la place créer
un conseil suprême des forces armées
simplement chargé des questions de
sécurité et de défense le but serait
selon lui de laisser la place à un
gouvernement civil ce que rejette ses
opposants qui souhaitent avant tout son
départ
on en vient à l'hommage national rendu
aux 21 jeunes morts il y a dix jours
dans la taverne daigneault bening prédit
ce clan donne en afrique du sud la cause
de leur décès est toujours inconnue et
les autopsies sont toujours en cours
beaucoup pointent du doigt l'abus
d'alcool sophie lamothe
dix neuf cercueils chacun avec le
portrait d'une des victimes des écoliers
des politiciens sont venus en nombre
pour rendre hommage à ses 21 jeunes
décédés dans un bar informel 10 london
il y a dix jours alors qu'ils fêtaient
la fin de leur examen le président cyril
ramaphosa a fait le déplacement il
accepte une part de responsabilité mais
pointent le doigt vers une consommation
excessive d'alcool des mineurs en
afrique du sud
il faut remettre la faute sur ceux qui
se font un profit sur le dos de la
jeunesse sud africaine
en enfreignant la loi et en vendant de
l'alcool à des malades a été levée des
analyses sont en cours
certains disent que les jeunes auraient
pu ingérer des produits toxiques des
rescapés explique qu'il aurait été gazés
et enfermé à l'intérieur du lieu par la
sécurité les parents demandaient la
fermeture de ce bar depuis des mois des
plaintes qui sont restées sans réponse
il ya une profonde frustration par
rapport à la façon dont les choses sont
gérées dans scénarii parc et par rapport
au fait que notre gouvernement ne répond
pas c'est qu'il fait la sourde oreille
face aux questions importantes
le chagrin collectif de ces dix derniers
jours se transforme aussi en colère les
parents soutiennent que ce tragique
incident aurait pu être évitée si les
autorités avaient investi dans des
infrastructures pour les jeunes et dans
le township en général pour eux cette
situation reflète une réalité de vie
plus général dans une afrique du sud
post apartheid
l'inquiétude des élites tunisiennes à la
proche du référendum pour la nouvelle
constitution la publication au journal
officiel du projet de constitution par
le président queille saeed a soulevé un
tollé y compris au sein de la société
civile ils sont nombreux à dénoncer
l'hyperprésident présidentialité du
pouvoir dans leur viseur en particulier
un article qui stipule que l'état doit
appliquer les finalités de l'islam
reportage de lilia blaise et abrite les
est la faculté des sciences juridiques
de tunis là où le président de la
république enseigne encore il ya
quelques années la majorité de ses
collègues s'inquiètent de ces mesures
pendant une journée d'étude
l'association de droit constitutionnel a
longuement décortiqué le nouveau texte
proposé par kay sayyed il n'y a aucune
possibilité de destituer le président
les compétences de la cour
constitutionnelle ont été réduites est
une règle aussi de bon sens il faut que
le pouvoir arrête le pouvoir s'il n'y a
pas un contre-pouvoir il y aura de
l'excès dans le pouvoir sinon
l'arbitraire au sein de l'opposition
certains ne veulent pas cautionner un
processus qu'ils estiment illégitime
plutôt que voter non ils appellent au
boycott du référendum le 25 juillet
comme cette coalition de partis
politiques
nous faisons campagne contre le
référendum que nous appelons à boycotter
car nous considérons que cette paire
titution n'est qu'une nouvelle étape
dans un processus de coup d'état qui
vise à installer un régime autoritaire
d'autres continuent de soutenir kaïs
ayed comme le poumon populaire un parti
nationaliste arabe qui appelle à voter
oui
ce nouveau texte constitutionnel
malgré les critiques dont il fait
l'objet et l'absence de certains
critiques nous pensons qu'il peut ouvrir
de nouveaux horizons et mettre en place
et figure d'autorité claire chose qui
était absente dans la constitution
précédant
le référendum doit se tenir dans trois
semaines dans un contexte politique
tendu et incertain selon ce politologue
le président de la république n'arrive
pas à donner de l'espoir à des tunisiens
qui sont en manque de confiance depuis
une dizaine d'années il n'arrive pas à
rendre les tunisiens optimiste un manque
d'optimisme qui pourrait mener vers un
passage en force selon le texte actuel
la constitution entre en vigueur juste
après les résultats du référendum quel
que soit le taux de participation
le texte ne précise pas non plus le
scénario si le nom l'emportent c'est la
fin journal de l'afrique rester avec
nous la faut continuer sur france 24
[Musique]